real housewives of atlanta star portia
williams is getting married to a former
friend's
ex portia did i hear something portia
are we gonna see you dating this season
or are you just taking time
for portia yes relationship things are
there
dennis is there and my baby girl you
know we're family
and all of that is spelled out
that was portia just six months ago
telling us her focus was on co-parenting
two-year-old daughter pilar with
ex-fiance dennis mckinley
now she's sporting an almost 12-carat
emerald cut rock
from simon culpatia after just one month
of dating
now you're going to want to pay
attention because this is where it gets
super complicated
simon's the x of porsche's former friend
phallic
porsche actually introduced fallon on a
housewife's episode
last december that makes me want to get
married all over again yes we may just
have to renew our vows ring upgrade
you know how the two ladies meet
porsha's baby daddy
introduced them dennis and simon
they knew each other they were in the
same industry she was really sweet
she's always been very real and genuine
so we clicked porsha says quote i had
nothing to do with simon and fallon's
divorce filing that's between the two of
them
this afternoon felon posted i am
focusing on finalizing my divorce
and healing oh and one more layer of
interesting
portia spent mother's day with her new
fiance and
ex-fiance dennis mckinley when you pray
for a purpose in your relationship which
is what i have been praying for
during this quarantine you don't know
what god is going to lay
upon you
you